it's a long car ride back from where we
were in california now we're in utah
stranger things never disappoints when
it comes to 80s nostalgia so we're
taking a look behind the scenes to find
out just how they turned back time and
gave us gnarly sets like the wrinkamania
and surfer boy pizza
number one the best sets are the ones
you can goof around on honestly this
week at the roller rink has been a blast
the rinko mania was shot in the roller
king in albuquerque new mexico every day
at lunch millie connects her phone and
we just skate around the ring does
anyone else think those safety mats just
look kind of uncomfortable number two
we're not talking about eleven's water
tank not this time no we're talking
about steve's dive to the bottom of love
lake to watergate it was in a big
convention center in atlanta by the
airport it was shot in a giant tank how
big do you think it was guys it went
roughly 40 feet around and 16 feet down
getting to do that sort of stuff is like
true
movie magic originally joe was told he'd
have to be a swimmer there was supposed
to be a whole arc in season one and he
was supposed to show up in a speedo so
he was like oh shoot i have to get in
shape then they cut it this swimming
plotline made its return for season four
he could already swim before though
number three ah yes the only thing worse
than prison is snow prison the scenes
set in russia were actually filmed in
lithuania in the same city used to film
chernobyl we shot in a
real prison the prison only closed in
2019 after running for over a century
for a lot of it i'm running shoeless
through the snows of lithuania david
harbour admitted it was very difficult
this year for me it was a lot of cold
weather it was barefoot in the snow in
lithuania 20 feet below and i wasn't
eating a lot of food because i was very
emaciated this season and so it was a
brutal season on me physically and
emotionally so i found my inner wolf
my inner russian bear
while it was tough harbor found he
really loves doing work like this
because he feels it provides the
audience with a rich experience allows
them catharsis and says he is very happy
to suffer in that way and before we hop
on over to the video store the plane
crash was absolutely ridiculous and
that's exactly what the film crew was
going for when it does an immediate nose
dive upon the engine being turned off
that's actually an homage to 80s movies
planes will glide slowly to the ground
without power
number four as abandoned as a
blockbuster
the video store is a very clear and
blatant expression of everything that
inspires the show the video store was
shot both interior and exterior after
they abandoned the location the only
thing remaining was their store hours
unfortunately those don't seem to be
very accurate they should just stay
closed the palace arcade from the
previous season is right beside the
video store and in a previous life in
the right side up aka our world the
whole thing was a laundry mat number
five into the rabbit hole we go we can't
say we're surprised this was filmed in
studio it would be rather ridiculous to
scout out a location for it of course
all of the vines in vechna's lair were
added in post got a little scraped up
but it was really really fun number six
they just can't quite shake this place
huh hawkins lab is back again for season
four and the rainbow room is all decked
out with padding we imagine to protect
all the children who are being thrown
against walls in these scenes
emory university's briar cliff campus in
atlanta georgia was used for the lab
number seven that feel when you graduate
middle school but your high school is no
different hawkins high and middle school
used the same abandoned school property
while this may seem like a lazy choice
architects of a similar period often
build schools similar shapes and designs
stranger things is not strapped for cash
so this seems more like an aesthetic
choice than a lazy one for season four
they painted the track and we said
goodbye to the middle school now that
our youngest characters have entered
grade nine and it looks like the
basketball players were having a ton of
fun on set making up handshakes and
playing ball on their time off number
eight time to drive three thousand miles
to find a hacker they were hanging out
in utah at susie's house actually we're
in atlanta but we don't say that we're
not exactly sure of the address other
than the street number saying 308 and
susie's bedroom was filmed on a
soundstage a mix of practical staging
and green screen was used probably
because that front door is facing a road
and they only wanted trees probably
number nine
phone home to hawkins filming for the
fictional california location lenora
hills actually took place in new mexico
that was millie's favorite location to
shoot in the interior of the buyer's
home was shot on a sound stage the
exterior was filmed in the shadow hills
area in albuquerque moving the family to
california was in honor of e.t lenora
high was also shot at eldorado high
school in albuquerque as well number ten
we genuinely didn't think this one was
built from scratch yes it's true the
demogorgon pit was not a found location
it serves the function of sort of this
gladiatorial arena their challenge was
to justify a space with oversized
dimensions it's all bleak rusted metal
with ancient brick and plaster walls
number eleven once you strip away the
movie magic the krill house is almost
pretty the krill house is called the
claremont house in real life it is far
less spooky when it isn't boarded up and
is almost elegant at one point it was a
bed and breakfast for 16 years but now
it is privately owned the house was
built in 1882 and remains in good
condition the upside down version of the
creel house is on the other hand all
fragmented pieces and not cgi number
twelve do you think they knew ahead of
time this location would come back they
filmed at stone mountain cemetery in
stone mountain georgia it's the same
cemetery they used for barb's funeral in
season 2. prep for the cemetery took a
lot more work than it may seem just
expect that when you've got stunts
involved that requires rigs and sadie's
stunt was practiced off location before
they moved on in
number thirteen we love the way they've
been building up the world in subtle
ways the trailer park was briefly
mentioned in season two when nancy and
jonathan said it was a good place to
meet with barb's mother
but didn't make a real appearance until
this season forest hills was filmed at a
real trailer park in griffin georgia
number 14. anybody remember that phone
number while the chain may not be real
walmart did partner with stranger things
for some frozen pizzas did you manage to
snag your own for binge watching the
shots were filmed in los lunas new
mexico and they also had multiple surfer
boy pizza vans on site too but the first
van they went with just did not do the
trick while it looked really cool it
just didn't have the space they needed
on the inside so they switched to a vw
we shot like a stoner
thriller
comedy kind of number 15 not an ideal
way to spend a day but anything for the
shot we suppose penhurst mental hospital
is located in atlanta and shot in
georgia while the building was closed in
1987 it was reopened as a halloween
attraction both the interior and
exterior of this scene were filmed on
location other than victor kriel's cell
scene which was filmed in studio
it was like
so fun and like different we can always
count on stranger things to deliver the
best 1980s sets even benny's burgers
made a small appearance but seeing it
all boarded up just breaks our little
hearts did this season get you feeling
nostalgic for the 1980s if you were born
in the 90s and beyond did it make you
long to live in the 80s let us know in
the comments and thanks for hanging out
with us here at the things